hey guys it's Lucy Hale and I am here at
BuzzFeed to answer your burning
questions what was it like filming the
Riverdale Katie King crossover with
Camila Mendes okay these are not I
thought they were gonna be like when did
you lose your virginity oh my god what
was it like it was amazing
Katie keen obviously has already
premiered but the day before it
premiered you got an introduction into
who Katie was Katie keen takes place
like five years in the future so in
order for Katie to go to Riverdale I had
to go back in time to become a teenager
and it was really fun
camis amazing and Veronica is the tie-in
for Katie and Riverdale they've been
friends their whole life so do you
prefer acting in movies or TV shows and
why actually prefer commercials now I'm
just kidding um I think you know most of
my work has been in TV and that's cool
because you get to live with a character
for a lot longer and there's a lot of
structure and stability and like
structures they're good for me but
movies are cool because you can Bop
around and play different characters I'm
not gonna choose cuz I don't I don't
want to but I've been lucky so far that
I get to do to do both which is really
great woo this one's hot must be good
I'm so dumb if you could bring one PLL
character - Katie keen who would it be
and why oh that's a great question
Hanna Marin would fit in well in like
the Katie Keane world you know cuz
Hanna's are already always in fashion on
PLL Katie's in fashion cool just pitched
an idea maybe they'll do that what song
would you sing at Molly's crisis what
would Katie sing she would seem like
Material Girl by Madonna or something
something about things and clothes and
fashion Lucy would sing Alanis
Morissette you ought to know
do you have any ideas for future
crossovers with Riverdale or chillin
Adventures of Sabrina can you spill any
details on if we'll see more crossovers
in the future so one of the actors on
Sabrina is on Katie Keane I can't say
who he plays we have a couple people
from Riverdale that come on in Katie
Keene also can't say who I think some of
them are already leaked like Hyrum Lodge
is they posted a picture so hopefully
that wasn't spoiler but whatever I
already said it so too late do you have
any stories from filming Katie Keene
with Ashley Marie I mean she's the best
we always have a blast and it's so cool
that her character is being showcased on
Katie Keene because I was always like
how did they work your character into
Riverdale cuz Riverdale still so dark
and mysterious and you know she's a
musician so we really get to showcase
her her music and she sings like an
angel and she's so sweet
people often compare PLL in Riverdale
huh do you think they're similar people
do compare people compared like PLL to
Twin Peaks and stuff there's always
gonna be comparisons you always draw
inspiration from other things and I
think it's flattering after PLL ended
Riverdale started airing so I think
those fans went straight into Riverdale
there are some similarities but I mean
it's a teen drama about murders so yes
definitely some similarities there which
project of yours would you rewatch right
now if you had to I don't like watching
my work none but Katie Keens really fun
I'm really proud of it but Fantasy
Island is going out too and that's
really fun in a completely different way
so maybe I'm coming around maybe I can
actually start watching some of my stuff
it's only taken me 15 years to not want
to cry after watching Tim
what's your favorite outfit from Katy
Keens so far it's in the finale I'm
wearing this big what am I trying to say
use your words loose feathers oh my god
feathers
it's like feather dress that makes a
heart kind of around my head it's really
hard to explain but it's very cool and
it's very katy and we end the show on a
very extreme Katy keynote which TV shows
are you currently obsessed with cheer
I just finished here where is Jerry I
need a Jerry in my life I love Morgan i
watch that show and I'm like how did
they put their bodies through that so
impressive shits Creek yeah that's
pretty much what I'm watching now I
might go re-watch the cheer actually
it's so good Jerry he's like yeah you
are gorgeous
we all need a Jerry in our life
besides Josie which riverdale character
would you love to have a cameo on Katie
keen like Archie like he's a boxer ko
who katie is dating is a boxer and
Archie also has storylines with Josie so
I feel like that would make sense but we
would be happy to have anyone who do you
relate to more Katie came from Katie key
or Aria Montgomery from elo I would say
Katie because her story of chasing her
dreams and wanting to become a designer
remind me a lot of my story of moving to
LA and wanting to become an actress and
we both have like the same kind of
optimism for life and passion about life
funny enough Katie and Ari are both like
very romantic which I am NOT so that's
how we differ but but I see a lot of
myself in Katie for sure would you
rather spend a day fighting crime with
Archie Betty Veronica and Jughead in
Riverdale or fight a demon with Sabrina
Spellman and chilling Adventures of
Sabrina Sabrina's a badass I feel like
that would be so fun and that's
something I have never taken on in the
acting world fighting a demon so that's
what I do yeah
all right guys thank you so much for
your questions that was a lot of fun
be sure to check out Katie Keane
Thursdays on the CW and Fantasy Island
in theaters right now
[Music]